non mais évidemment on est très content
pour les enfants Ukrainiens mais quand
on regarde de plus près ça pose quand
même question on nous explique toute
l'année qui a pas d'argent pour
accueillir les enfants dans les crèches
qui a pas d'argent pour accueillir les
SDF qui a pas d'argent pour accueillir
d'autres réfugiés et là en un coup de
baguette magique le gouvernement sort
des millions parce que ça coûte des
millions et ça coûte énormément d'argent
pour les enfants Ukrainiens donc moi je
comprends que ça divise et je comprends
que on puisse être en colère contre ça
s'appelle nécessaire c'est pas une
nécessité ils ont fui la guerre avec
leurs parents c'est pas quand tu fuis la
guerre avec leur maman mais quand tu
fais la guerre à la crèche tu fais quoi
tu fais de la peinture c'est pas une
nécessité tu m'aurais dit d'école
primaire je t'aurais dit oui c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup de Français qui
galèrent à mettre leurs enfants à la
crèche qui sont sur des listes
d'attentes qui bossent qui peuvent pas
mettre leurs enfants à la crèche alors
c'est dramatique et moi je suis content
qu'on accueille les enfants à craignant
il y a aucun souci mais expliquez-moi là
maintenant la nécessité de mettre vite
un enfant ukrainien à la place de
d'autres familles qui sont en France qui
arrive pas à trouver de place en crèche
est-ce qu'il va faire qui bosse oui mais
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire l'enfant à la
crèche le petit tu craignais est-ce
qu'il va faire la CAF elle dit dans dans
les arguments de la cave c'est de dire
que en fait ça permet à un moment de
répit pour les parents ou les
ukrainienne dans leur quand elles font
faire leur démarche elles des démarches
d'accueils il faut aider les moments il
faut aider les moments à faire des
démarches
il faut qu'elle fasse les démarches pour
les aider c'est pas ils vont pas s'en
sortir si ceux qui parlent pas français
ils vont pas s'en sortir donc forcément
faudra les aider mais comment on aide
les je les parents qui travaillent aussi
et ouais c'est ça le problème moi ce qui
me révolte c'est que en France c'est le
18% des petits sont accueillis en crèche
il y a pas de place vous devez passer
par une commission d'attribution les
mairies vous donnent jamais de place moi
je vous dis un truc parce que c'est vrai
combien j'ai eu de potes de parents qui
m'ont appelé qui m'ont dit Cyril est-ce
que tu peux appeler la mairie un truc
est-ce que tu connais pas quelqu'un qui
peut prendre mon enfant à la crèche je
suis en galère totale chaque année j'ai
une dizaine de personnes j'ai dit je
suis je travaille pas
c'est maman enceintes déjà enceintes
elles cherchent elles cherchent des
places à la crèche donc déjà quand on
est enceinte on se dit pour dans un an
pendant voilà et là comme par miracle on
trouve des milliers de place alors c'est
très bien pour les petits Ukrainiens qui
apprendra par les Français mais tous les
petits Français qui galèrent et leurs
parents je trouve ça dingue c'est comme
les les milliards qu'on libère quand il
y a des crises économiques et tout ça si
l'argent il est là qu'on le donne au
pauvres s'il y a des places en crèche
qu'on accueille les petits Français ça
me semble d'un coup on découvre qu'on
peut tout faire alors on va dire vous
allez dire que c'est des magots etc même
quand on débloque de l'argent pour
certaines choses comme on avait bloqué
énormément d'argent là il y avait un
truc qui est important c'était plus
personne dans la rue ouais
de plus en plus d'argent dans la rue je
vais vous dire avec ce qui se passe
actuellement il y a de plus en plus de
gens qui travaillent qui gagnent leur
vie et qui le disent ou le 11 du mois se
retrouve sans rien il y en a qui dansent
dans leur voiture il y a des mecs qui
dorment dans leur voiture qui peut même
plus prendre leur voiture parce que
quand tu fais le plein d'essence si tu
dis c'est un dernier et aujourd'hui
je vous dis la priorité pour moi il faut
vraiment que ça ça devienne une priorité
le pouvoir d'achat et
aider les plus démunis quand on trouve
de l'argent je suis d'accord Gilles
voilà pour pour les vaccins pour pour
d'autres choses on se dit pourquoi c'est
pas une priorité plus personne dans la
rue et aider aussi ceux qui aujourd'hui
je vous dis il y a de plus en plus de
gens qui travaillent et qui s'en sortent
pas c'est ça qui est grave c'est quand
tu travailles tu te dis je travaille et
je suis fier de travailler et je veux
m'en sortir aujourd'hui tu as plein de
gens qui travaillent mais qui n'arrivent
pas à s'en sortir et ça ça c'est une
admissible c'est vrai que on aimerait
voilà je dis il y a les bien sûr il y a
des aides en France je le dis pas c'est
quand même un pays où on est de beaucoup
plus qu'ailleurs mais c'est vrai que on
se dit parfois il y a une baguette
magique il y a la machine à habiller qui
qui peut être utilisé sur certaines
choses et pas sur d'autres et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que pour le
prochain président quel qu'il soit il
faudra vraiment aller voter d'ailleurs
dimanche quel qu'il soit la priorité ça
doit être tous ces gens qui travaillent
aussi et qui ne s'en sortent pas
qui je vous dis qui vivent avec le
stress avec la peur au ventre c'est à
dire que dès le 10 du mois ils ont la
peur au ventre ils se disent comment on
va faire et ça je pense qu'il faut
essayer de débloquer de l'argent comme
ils ont pu le faire sur d'autres sujets
et ça c'est bien que tu le dis Gilles
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un peu ça
rejoint ça rejoint le truc Géraldine non
évidemment alors par rapport aux
Ukrainiens évidemment il y a des
convictions de plateau et on a envie
d'aider tout le monde et tout ça
effectivement concrètement quand on est
une maman seule qu'on élève son enfant
dans des familles monoparentales et
qu'on voit qu'on est en liste d'attente
et que ça passe jamais qu'il y a un
enfant ukrainien qui va passer devant
vous bah oui c'est le slogan de Trump
c'est America First bah c'est friends
first et évidemment on a envie de penser
à notre priorité nationale et d'ailleurs
ça donne une très bonne indication je
pense de ce qui va se passer dimanche au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle alors et il y a des gens
qui disent ça veut dire quoi justement
est-ce que vous avez une réponse il y a
des gens qui disent ça veut dire qu'on
se fout de notre gueule quand on lui dit
terrorisme
qui n'a pas de place en crèche qui bosse
et on lui dit elle doit passer un enfant
étranger même si c'est impossible c'est
explicable ça va mettre les gens en
colère voilà les gens vont en colère
surtout que c'est impossible
mais là c'est vrai qu'à un moment à un
moment mais Cyril il faut faire
attention
il y a pas de place aujourd'hui oui il a
commencé à il y avait de la place pour
jésus-christes pas là c'est très
compliqué la prochaine fois
bien sûr et puis en plus je pense que
les gens disent souvent pourquoi tout
d'un coup il y a de l'argent bah c'est
ça même pendant tout d'un coup il est
milliards quoi qu'il en coûte
il y a plus la crise et économiquement
c'est assez simple c'est un gouvernement
qui décide d'émettre de l'argent ça veut
dire que tu crées en fait de la dette et
de l'inflation économiquement c'est
assez simple en fait je vais débuter sur
un bouton et créer de l'argent donc là
non seulement effectivement on a trouvé
de l'argent pour des gens pardon mais
qui ne sont pas français même si c'est
très triste alors qu'elle n'a pas pour
les Français mais en plus de ça du coup
on a créé de la dette
pour les Français parce qu'évidemment
tout ça vous le paierez un jour des
enfants la dette vous la paierez un jour
et moi je suis un peu comme vous
évidemment il y a un truc que je suis
touché c'est forcément ces enfants là
qui ont vécu la guerre ils sont
traumatisés à vie ces mots-là ils seront
traumatisés à vie maintenant encore une
fois le fait qu'on soit français et
qu'on soit un pays d'accueil fait que
dès qu'on dit non à quelque chose on
nous tombe dessus mais il y a un moment
bah oui pardon et si on peut déjà
s'occuper dedans
j'aimerais bien voir le quoiqu'il en
coûte pour ceux voilà en grosses
difficultés
à la fin du mois voilà
il serait là je vous dis nous on est on
est ici je vous dis on le redis à chaque
fois on gagne très bien notre vie tous
moi particulièrement et je l'ai toujours
dit voilà c'est vrai mais on est on
aimerait voir tout le monde heureux
quand on voit des gens et moi on a
vaincu des gilets jaunes ici les vrais
gilets jaunes voilà qui sont en
difficulté c'est pour ça qu'ils étaient
sortis dans la rue à la base parce que
le 10 du mois on le dit souvent c'est
l'image qu'on prend ils sont ils sont à
la rue ils ont ils peuvent plus manger
donc aujourd'hui je pense que le quoi
qu'il en coûte pour le prochain
président ça doit être sur ces personnes
qui travaillent ces personnes qui
travaillent bien sûr il faut les aider
exactement aussi mais ces personnes qui
travaillent qui ne s'en sortent pas
parce que c'est ça qu'on voit fleurir et
on voit ça c'est ce qu'on voit de plus
en plus les gens travaillent ils ont un
bon taf ils travaillent ils veulent se
réveille le matin il se couche tard le
soir il travaille comme des chiens et en
plus ils ont la possibilité
il sait déjà qu'il arrivera pas allez
jusqu'à la fin du mois parce que à la
fin du mois déjà il sera découvert comme
tu as dit le 10 le 15 la banque va lui
mettre des ajouts parce que moi tu as
l'argent en plus tu pourras jamais
et que vous vous dites qu'est-ce qui va
se passer il y a Noël qui arrive ou bien
quand votre fille si vous dit maman j'ai
vu le j'ai vu un copain à l'école
et que tu dis ben je peux pas
humiliant quand tu on vit pas ça mais
quand tu as le copain qui dit mon pote
il a été Astérix mon pote il a été à
Disney mon pote il a telle fringues mon
pote a-t-elle console pour un parent
c'est humiliant parce que moi j'ai rien
en fait c'est à dire je me lève le matin
je prends le train mais en fait aux yeux
de mes enfants je suis associé ça je
cours après le RER à 6h du matin le 10
du mois je suis à découvert je demande à
des gens de me prêter un peu d'argent
même pas de sous pour mettre d'essence
dans ma voiture et aux yeux de mes
enfants en plus de ça je suis un tocard
et à côté de ça tu as des gens qui
travaillent pas en France et qu'à eux
par contre on leur donne tout c'est ça
le problème le prochain président tu
disais toi c'est comme regarde je vais
même le truc le truc de la cantine je
vais plus loin moi j'ai parlé avec mon
voisin je lui dis mais pourquoi je
comprends pas votre voisin non mon
voisin tu comprends pas toi tu fais des
voitures sur les parkings c'est bien ta
nanas elle est toute la journée au
téléphone pourquoi ton enfant il va à la
cantine est-ce qu'il m'a répondu c'est
50 centimes la cantine question que je
me casse les couilles ça a coûté plus
cher il reste là je vais même à côté de
ça je paye 5 € 20 mois c'est moi qui
paye la cantine pour ton fils il me dit
qu'est-ce que j'en ai à [ __ ] t'as qu'à
changer de métier il m'a dit il a raison
le système il est comme ça c'est pas
normal c'est pas normal tu as des gens
qui payent la cuisine alors que c'est
plein d'autres problèmes comme ça
le matin qui travaille toute la journée
et qui se retrouvent dans la merde
partout pour moi pour moi ça doit être
priorité j'envoie qui parle là il
s'arrête pas de parler et de et de ce
qu'ils connaissent pas Cyril et
franchement je vous le dis ça oui c'est
pas la priorité c'est dans les banlieues
parce qu'on en voit souvent des
reportages sur les banlieues on voit que
tout va mal il y a aussi des gens qui
sont extrêmement heureux dans les
banlieues il y a une solidarité
incroyable et il faut arrêter de dire
oui être et voilà ils vont jamais ils
vont jamais dans les banlieues à 6h30 du
matin pour voir les arrêts de bus sont
pas vides les arrêts de bus il y a des
gens qui attendent le bus regardez les
bus à 6h dans les matins dans le matin
le bus quand je suis arrêté en camion
j'ai un bus à côté de moi mais il est
rempli à 6h du matin
ou qui avec qui sont ça se passe il y en
a plein ou ça se passe très bien mais ça
on le voit jamais donc forcément et
alors donc c'est ça devient une priorité
pour pour la la cette campagne là je
vous dis la priorité pour cette campagne
des Français c'est ceux qui travaillent
et qui s'en sortent pas et ça c'est
vraiment
les loyers à 900 balles 800 balles 1000
balles machines il faut arrêter tout la
bulle spéculative des loyers moi avant
c'est les loyers c'était 1500 francs
2000 francs et rien du tout loyer c'est
la moitié de ton salaire moyen quand on
aide les patrons si il faudrait qu'ils
aient des patrons à voir
vérifier que les mecs ils donnent plus
d'oseille au gars parce que si tu si tu
enlèves les charges
gilet jaune quand même quand notre dame
a brûlé c'était un drame évidemment bien
sûr ils ont trouvé en une journée 800
900 millions et ça je comprends que les
gens que les gens il est beau c'est pas
possible
tu peux dire est-ce que tu peux dire
aujourd'hui dis-moi de temps en temps tu
peux leur dire éventuellement il n'y a
plus d'argent c'est très dur mais tu
peux l'entendre mais tu peux pas leur
dire il y a plus d'argent pour vous
ouais mais il y en a pour les autres
regardez il y a quelqu'un il y a une
amie qui me dit euh qui est dans ce
samedi moi je bosse et j'ai pas d'aide
car tu gagnes trop et en contrepartie tu
gagnes pas assez pour bouffer
elle a raison ton ami le gagne trop pour
expliquer aux gens le gagne trop c'est
pas c'est pas 4000 €, c'est pas 5000 €
le gagne trop c'est 1005 1008 ça veut
dire qu'il y aura pas d'appel tu auras
pas d'allocations familiale la cantine
tu vas la payer plein pot le passe
Navigo tu vas tout payer plein pot tout
tu vas tout payer et tu seras imposable
et parfois tu as des gens à côté qui
veulent pas travailler qui foutent rien
depuis des années des années on sait
qu'il faut que rien il cherche pas à la
montée
il cherche pas taf et à la fin à la fin
de l'année si tu calcules tout ce que tu
as payé et tout ce qu'il a payé avec ses
aides avec 200 € de loyer l'appel et
tout ça il a perdu 200 balles sur toi
mais c'est pas levé tous les matins il a
rien fait donc c'est c'est ça qu'il faut
changer alors je regrette qu'on vienne
sur l'Ukraine voilà et sur ses enfants
Ukrainiens accueillis gratuitement dans
nos crèches françaises comprenez-vous
que ça divise on continue ce débat dans
un instant mais justement Benjamin toi
tu es toi tu l'as dit ça tu es déjà
juste Delphine qui est quand même je
mets à la place des gens c'est
impossible d'aller dire à une famille il
y a pas de place pour son enfant quand
il est vue passer et ce drame qui est
humain il y a pas de doute là-dessus
mais c'est impossible les gens ils vont
être en colère mais c'est pas la mettre
en colère un enfant écrivain c'est pas
la priorité qu'il aille en crèche qu'il
aille en primaire oui il aille au
collège oui tu l'as accueilli on l'a
accueilli on l'accueilli l'enfant il est
créé on accueilli sa mère on va l'aider
on va lui donner à manger on va lui
donner un toit ça y est on l'a sorti de
la guerre la priorité c'est pas d'aller
faire des coloriages du de Bozo le clown
avec la peinture on s'en fout c'est pas
sa priorité on lui a sauvé la ville et
heureux avec sa mère maintenant il est
en sécurité la priorité c'est pas
d'aller faire de de sauter dans des
cerceaux dans un cours on s'en fout de
ça il fera ça plus tard en primaire
sympa votre crèche en tout cas il y en a
qu'une qui comprend pas que ça dévissait
Delphine pourquoi oui parce que bah
aujourd'hui je trouve qu'en France enfin
l'état aide bien quand même alors je
suis d'accord qu'il faut baisser les
charges il faut augmenter les salaires
ça c'est un truc mais après je trouve
que l'État est relativement bien ensuite
Raymond toi tu disais attends les petits
Ukrainiens ils ont pas besoin d'aller à
la crèche ils ont pas besoin de faire de
la peinture et en même temps il y a
certains Français c'est con à Noël ils
peuvent offrir la play à leurs enfants
mais qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout là vous
êtes sur du matériel alors que les
petits Ukrainiens eux ils ont vu la
guerre ils ont peut-être perdu leur
grand-parents leur maison s'est fait
bombardé alors oui ils ont besoin de
faire de la peinture ils veulent se
changer les idées
un petit problème qui me dérange je vous
dis l'Ukraine moi je suis à fond pour
les aider à 100%
seulement actuellement se passe
énormément de choses au Mali
et moi j'aimerais bien qu'on aide le
Mali également
c'est une question de volonté politique
en fait il faut aider
ma géométrie c'est pas de la solidarité
c'est de la volonté politique et
Delphine elle dit l'état nous aide bien
c'est pas vrai on est dans un pays où
énormément de gens surtout les classes
moyennes comme le dirai mon et les
classes les épées énormément d'impôts
ceux qui sont censés en bénéficier
c'est-à-dire les plus démunis non
bénéficient pas et on se dit où va
l'argent bah il va là-dedans dans des
choses complètement tertiaires et je
trouve ça nul on a quand même aussi de
la chance l'école est gratuite chez nous
là
dans d'autres pays aussi pour voir
comment ça se passe sur vous des films
qui dit Delphine qui n'a pas de gosse et
son mari a les moyens de payer une
crèche privée va nous dire comment on
doit bien penser petit peuple que l'on
est voilà mais non mais pas du tout je
dis juste que vous vous parliez de à
Noël on peut pas offrir la dernière
plaie où les derniers fringues à son
enfant
le comment dire le besoin est plus
primaire c'est à dire ne pas mourir ne
se changer d'idées et c'est pas pareil
que d'abord le dernier truc à la mode
les associations peuvent faire ça
comment vous allez expliquer à la
rentrée c'est impossible un enfant qui
n'a pas de place en crèche comment vous
allez m'expliquer ce sont des gens qui
sortent de la guerre je suis désolé
c'est différent non mais on n'a pas
besoin
ces petits ont pas besoin de faire de la
peinture moi je dis que si il doit se
changer les idées parce qu'ils ont vu
des choses que peut-être nous tous on
verra jamais et on l'espère il y a plein
de petits Français à Noël un cadeau en
moi ou un cadeau en plus je vous ai déjà
dit je suis pas sur le matériel à Noël
il faudrait même pas faire la course au
cadeau faudrait juste passer des bons
moments
qu'est-ce que tu fais de ton enfant
c'est le parcours du combattant
des milliers des centaines de milliers
de petits français il faut il faut
répondre à des critères infernaux
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ces petits qui
ont perdu leur maison peut-être leurs
parents qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
petits Français qui n'ont pas de place
de crèche qui n'ont rien les crèches
municipales c'est impossible
revenir un peu en arrière on va se
rapprocher du giron familial des
grands-parents
c'est pas possible mais il y a plein de
Français qui font ça les grands
vous êtes à chaise
dans la famille c'est tout aussi bien
que des inconnus qui gagne
à Paris tous les jours tu fermes tes
enfants on parle de place en Crète
des parents déjà tes grands-parents ils
ont peut-être 45 50 ans ils travaillent
encore ils peuvent pas cuire tes enfants
et puis encore une fois oui on entend ce
que tu dis mais la question n'est
beaucoup plus simple c'est qu'est-ce que
tu fais de tes enfants toi tu as les
moyens d'aimer d'une crèche privée
quelque part qu'est-ce que tu fais de
tes enfants quand tu ne peux pas les
mettre dans une crèche et que tu es
français c'est que le matin quand tu
sais pas quoi en faire qu'on t'explique
que le problème vient l'Ukraine pardon
mais tu payes des impôts problème Cyril
quand vous me dites je suis hors-sol en
fait moi je suis tout sauf hors sol je
dis juste que les Ukrainiens aujourd'hui
ils ont un problème de vie ou de mort et
nos petits français c'est d'autres mais
on les appuis
les accueillir dans les crèches et nous
on est sur l'association qui n'a pas ça
est-ce que c'est normal
150 € d'impôts tous les mois tous les
mois est-ce que c'est normal qu'on lui
dit ton enfant il ira pas la crèche
c'est normal ou pas non mais réponds-moi
en fait ça c'est le même problème que
les hôpitaux que les policiers c'est la
même chose il faut créer des places de
prison il faut créer des places de
crèche il faut créer plus d'école mais
pourquoi tu dis que ça n'a rien à voir
il faut faire plus de crèche ça donnera
plus de boulot aux gens
là
c'est 400 crêpes pendant les vacances
mais dites-le au prochain au prochain
président justement parce que c'est la
faute le temps que ça on ouvre plus
hôpitaux et plus de prison
par l'absurde mais s'il y a des milliers
c'est votre démonstration s'il y a des
milliers de place de crèches pourquoi
est-ce que les petits Français n'en
bénéficient pas c'est pour ça que je les
a maintenu vite c'est crèche s'il y a
des places qu'on trouve par miracle
maintenant pour des petits Ukrainiens
qui méritent ce que dit la fille on n'a
pas compris
moi je pense que tu as dit le mot
solidarité en fait je pense qu'il
faudrait les Français comprendraient
bien mieux et serait certainement très
généreux organisé quelque chose il y a
des mamans retraités qui pourraient
peut-être prendre les petits Ukrainiens
va prendre le français ou à faire des
démarches ça c'est bien quelque chose à
imaginer je pense qu'il serait beaucoup
plus accepté il y a plein de gens qui
peuvent donner de leur temps alors que
ça oui c'est une mesure qui n'est pas
acceptée vous vous rendez compte que le
31 mars c'est il y a 6 jours il y a eu
une grève nationale on en a très peu
parlé justement sur le problème sur le
problème des crèches et de la petite
enfance et des gens qui sont dans ce
métier disent en ce moment que c'est en
train de devenir l'EHPAD pour les pour
les petits donc si justement la
situation est grave et on nous annonce
que on trouve des places pour les
Ukrainiens bien sûr que c'est mal
accepté il faut imaginer autre chose la
solidarité oui mais pas de cette façon
là non mais Delphine elle était sur un
débat et je trouve que tu as raison à
long terme c'est à dire que oui bien sûr
plus de place dans les prisons
plus de place des hôpitaux oui
évidemment intelligents mais maintenant
c'est un cas de force majeure
aujourd'hui à la rentrée concrètement tu
es une maman et tu vois qu'il y a un
petit ukrainien qui passe avant ton fils
alors que tu es enceinte et que tu
galères
c'est inaudible en fait c'est eux qui
sont en feu mais tu as pas compris de
quoi ma chérie il dit les parents ils
sont en feu mais c'est c'est les
Ukrainiens qui sont en feu c'est tout le
pays qui en feu mais enfin il y a
combien de pays au monde
peut-être qu'on est minoritaire on s'en
fout des mauvaises c'est pas grave
quoi
80,6 du match comprends quelque chose
c'est c'est dur ce que je veux dire mais
quand quand tu ne sais pas quoi bouffer
dans ta journée oui pardon mais savoir
ce qui se passe ailleurs ce que je veux
dire mais ce qui se passe dans d'autres
pays je dirais pas que tu t'en fous
c'est horrible mais c'est ton concret à
toi et ces gens-là c'est leur journée
chaque jour c'est bouffé c'est finir le
moi c'est elle est logée leurs enfants
donc pardon ce qui se passe en Ukraine
c'est horrible parce que je veux dire
mais c'est c'est